[Music]
an undead city under siege soldiers and
police ruthlessly shooting down waves of
zombies that flood from infected streets
trying to escape and infect more cities
this is what happens when your body
fights cancer more exciting than any
movie how does this battle for survival
unfold
[Music]
1. the elimination phase it all begins
with a single corrupted cell it's no
longer able to repair its genetic code
it can't kill itself anymore and it's
beginning to multiply rapidly at this
point things are not great not terrible
this cell is not yet dangerous but if
nothing happens it soon will be over a
few weeks the corrupt itself keeps
making copies of itself one cell turns
into dozens hundreds thousands because
the original was broken its copies are
breaking and mutating even more
they turn into different genetic
lineages plans that are working together
and competing some mutate in a way that
makes them weaker others mutations don't
change anything while a few become
fitter and better at survival together
they now form a tiny tiny tumor not
cancer yet but getting there the growing
tumor needs a lot of resources if the
cells don't get food and oxygen they'll
die and the problem just solves itself
unfortunately a few corrupted cells
unlock a new mutation that saves them
the ability to order the growth of new
blood vessels and so your body provides
the supply they need to survive but as
the tumor continues to grow it starts
causing damage neighboring healthy cells
begin to starve and die which attracts
attention in a sense this tiny tumor is
like a rogue Town imagine a group of
rebels in Brooklyn decide that they're
no longer part of New York and start a
new settlement called tuba town which
happens to occupy the same space the new
city wants to grow so it orders tons of
steel beams cement and drywall new
buildings follow no logic are badly
planned ugly and dangerously crooked
they're built right in the middle of
streets on top of playgrounds and on
existing infrastructure the old
neighborhood is torn down or overbuilt
to make room for new stuff many of the
former residents are trapped in the
middle of it and begin to starve this
goes on for a while until the smell of
death finally attracts attention
building inspectors and please show up
in your body attracted by the stench of
dead cells your immune system is
activated the first responder immune
cells invade the tumor macrophages and
natural killer cells police forces that
go right to work killing and eating
tumor cells they release chemical
signals that let the whole immune system
know that there is cancer to be
eradicated
dendritic cells the intelligence offices
of your immune system collect samples of
dead tumor cells and begin activating
your heavy weapons Helper and killer T
cells we explained these specialized
superweapons in another video but all
you really need to know is that they
have a library listing every bad thing
that could come into your body
one each cancer is unique there are
genetic Corruptions that they can't hide
and your T cells know what to look for
they are the deadliest cancer Killers
you have by the time they arrive the
tumor has grown to hundreds of thousands
of cells but this is about to change
T cells block the growth of new blood
vessels which starves thousands of tumor
cells and puts an end to their growth
imagine the building inspectors
switching off electricity and water and
putting up roadblocks to cancer town so
no more food or materials can be
delivered with no way to hide from the
Carnage unfolding the tumor collapses as
hundreds of thousands of tumor cells are
massacred their carcasses are cleaned up
and consumed by macrophages that then
order healthy tissue to regenerate
your body has crushed the illegal tumor
town without Mercy you'll never know
about this fight or how many times this
has happened inside your body except in
this case something didn't go as planned
[Music]
2. the equilibrium phase
unfortunately natural selection spores
your Victory by doing its best to
destroy the tumor your immune system
accidentally selects the fittest tumor
cells remember the tumor consists of
different lineages that keep growing and
keep mutating most of these are
eradicated but just a few are more
resilient
one cell survives it comes from the
fittest human lineage and was just a bit
better at surviving the massacre than
anyone else it decides to do it all over
again but better this time
this tumor cell is much stronger than
any of the thousands that were killed
maybe it's better at hiding or fighting
back maybe it grows faster or is better
at stealing resources maybe it can
survive with much less oxygen and so it
all begins again it's like the surviving
Rebels that started tumor town have
learned their lessons now they know the
law better and how to break it what
permits help them and how to avoid the
police and so the surviving tumor cell
makes thousands of copies that mutate
and form new lineages until once again
the tumor has grown made up of more
resilient cells
the immune system doesn't care though
and this time it even has experience
instead of starting with Police SWAT
teams go right into tear tumor town down
killing its inhabitants without Mercy
but once again they don't get everyone
one of them survives a fitter tumor cell
from an already fitter lineage this time
it gets a cheap suit and stutters the
building code pretending to be a lawyer
to start tumor town all over again this
struggle now repeats a few times each
time the rebels learn a bit more about
how to avoid the law if at any point the
immune system gets all of the tumor
cells the story ends but in this case it
doesn't
finally a tumor cell changes in a way
that makes it properly dangerous cancer
the type that kills people how immune
cells have an off switch that
deactivates them before they can attack
which in principle is a good idea the
immune system is extremely dangerous and
in many cases it needs to be shut down
like around your central nervous system
but this off switch can be exploited the
mutated tumor cell finds a way to switch
the immune system off by targeting
inhibitor receptors on anti-cancer cells
inhibitor receptors stop immune cells
from well killing this cell is now the
powerful founder of a new lineage of
cancer cells and mass produces thousands
of new copies that once again change and
mutate further building yet another
tuber town
three the Escape phase
the new cancer cells have become immune
to the immune system and everything is
different this time
tuber town has been rebuilt even uglier
and Stranger than before but now the
cancer city council has forged all sorts
of permits as building inspectors come
to shut down construction they get
confused
stunned they wander off unable to order
the destruction of the sprawling
buildings
please try to enter the illegal City to
arrest the builders and execute
inhabitants but this time tumor town has
erected its own roadblocks that keep the
law from entering confused officers
stand around helplessly as tumor Town
slowly envelops the former Brooklyn and
more and more civilians die T-cell SWAT
teams arrive to end this travesty but
things get worse new lineages of tuber
Town officials have started to forge
court documents that order police to
shoot at the SWAT teams
what the cancer cells are doing at this
point is actively shutting down immune
defenses by sending corrupt signals the
now malignant tumor is no longer a
pushover and has begun creating the
cancer microenvironment a sort of
Borderland that's hard to cross all
avenues of attack have been shut down
and uncontrollable growth is the
consequence this is a dangerous tumor
cells that are strong and able to fight
push your immune system back and expand
further if more mutations happen then
some of the cancer cells will begin to
explore the world and expand into other
tissues to build new towns and this is
exactly what makes cancer so harmful
it's taking up space and stealing so
many nutrients that your true self has
no room to function anymore
if this goes on for too long organs will
shut down but this tactic is a dead end
the more successful cancer gets the more
damage it does to its world when the
body dies the cancer dies too it truly
is a game without winners
except humanity is planning to win this
game at this very moment hundreds of
thousands of scientists are working on
new and better ways of killing cancer to
destroy and burn down tumor towns for
good in recent years immunotherapy has
made enormous progress It's a relatively
new therapy in which your own immune
cells are modified to kill cancer better
than any medicine can do it's like
giving your building inspectors machine
guns and flamethrowers
but this is a story for another time
for now cancer is a Battleground but if
human Ingenuity is to be trusted then
one day maybe in the not too distant
future we will eradicate it once and for
all
this video was made possible in part by
direct viewer support and in part
through a grant by Gates Ventures thanks
a lot for their support
please check out our source document for
more background and in-depth information
[Music]
no no no no no
wait
[Music]